io vorrei condividere con voi proprio lo
stupore che ho provato quando mi hanno
spiegato come le tecnologie esponenziali
stanno trasformando il mondo e per
questo intervento mi sono dato un
obiettivo ambizioso
vorrei che questo termine risultasse
indelebilmente fissato nella vostra
testa
vediamo se riuscirò a fare questo
un po come succede con questa immagine
piena di macchie
all'interno di questa immagine c'è un
cane eccolo qua ora che vi ho mostrato
il cane non riuscirete più a non vedere
il cane provateci un po ecco non ci
riuscite
perché si è creata una commissione
neurale permanente
vediamo se riesco a fare la stessa cosa
parlandovi di tecnologie esponenziali il
significato di questo termine l'ho
appreso frequentando la singolare
itinerante che si trova all'interno del
campus del centro di ricerca della nasa
a mountain view in california
e qui i maggiori esperti del mondo
studiano tecnologie come l'informatica
le biotecnologie l'intelligenza
artificiale per capirne gli impatti
positivi e negativi per la verità si fa
molto di più di questo ma di questo che
parlerò dopo stupore dicevo cosa hanno
di così speciale
queste tecnologie esponenziali hanno di
speciale che si sviluppano molto
lentamente e poi all'improvviso
esplodono un po come succede con pop
corn l'effetto pop corn ed abbiamo visto
ad esempio all'opera con internet
internet è stato inventato 50 anni fa
per 40 anni praticamente non se n'è
accorto nessuno
poi all'improvviso ma ogni pizzeria a un
sito miliardi di persone sono connessi
ad internet
il commercio elettronico ha raggiunto
quota 5 miliardi di dollari al giorno
internet è diventato il sistema nervoso
del pianeta ora non siamo stupiti di
questo ma se qualcuno se l'avesse detto
dieci anni fa ho 15 anni fa non ci
avremmo creduto perché perché quando il
progresso è già avvenuto
noi lo diamo per scontato mentre invece
quando dobbiamo fare delle previsioni
che facciamo in modo lineare come per
esempio in modo lineare ha pensato
mackensen quando nel 1984 ha stimato il
mercato mondiale dei telefoni cellulari
dell'anno 2000 la stima di making fiera
entro il 2000 ci saranno un milione di
telefoni cellulari
però nel 2000 ce n'erano 100 milioni e
ora sappiamo sappiamo che se ne sono
miliardi perché ha sbagliato perché qui
avevamo a che fare con un esponenziale
lo facciamo fatica a capire le
esponenziali ta e ora ve lo dimostro con
un esempio immaginate di fare trenta
passi da un metro in modo lineare 123
dopo trenta passi
sarò arrivato in fondo alla sala ora
provate a immaginare immaginate di fare
gli stessi trentapassi raddoppiando i
metri con ogni passo 248 16 dove sarete
arrivati dopo 30 di questi raddoppi
avrete percorso oltre un miliardo di
metri e che equivale a fare 26 volte il
giro della terra
quando mi hanno fatto questo esempio
sono rimasto basito stupore sono rimasto
basito perché mi ha fatto capire come
non siamo in grado di capire le
esponenziali ta per esempio ci viene
naturale pensare che dopo quindici passi
esponenziale quindi dopo 15 raddoppi
saremo a metà strada cioè circa 500
milioni di chilometri
invece dopo 15 raddoppi abbiamo fatto 30
chilometri che equivale alla distanza
fra como e lecco praticamente e non 13
volte il giro del pianeta
ma ritorniamo sui suoi cellulari
questo qui non è un telefonino questo è
un supercomputer che vent'anni fa
avrebbe riempito una stanza intera e che
fra vent'anni occuperà lo spazio di una
cellula e questo lo sappiamo
praticamente per certo grazie a questo
signore che si chiama records wine che
il fondatore della singolare university
nonché praticamente il futurista che ha
seccato più previsione di chiunque altro
al mondo
questa è la copertina di time dedicata
alle sue previsioni e alla sua famosa
curva esponenziale che so vediamo meglio
qui su questa slide questa curva
dimostra che l'efficienza informatica
per usare una semplificazione è andata
raddoppiando in maniera costante
praticamente da un secolo a questa parte
ancor prima dell'invenzione dei circuiti
integrati se proiettiamo questa curva in
avanti fra dieci anni con mille euro
saremo in grado di comprare la capacità
di calcolo di un cervello umano e fra 30
anni quando cioè i miei figli avranno
più o meno la metà
la capacità di calcolo di tutti i
cervelli umani
cosa significa questo
questo significa che si verificherà la
cosiddetta singolarità tecnologica cioè
quel momento ipotetico nel tempo in cui
le macchine diventano più intelligenti
di noi soltanto perché cresce in maniera
così enorme la capacità di calcolo
questo non lo sa nessuno e non lo sa
nemmeno la singolarità university
proprio non lo sa nessuno però è certo
che questo è un tema molto importante e
dobbiamo come dire avere un dibattito su
questo su questo tema che per la verità
è già cominciato e che pone degli
interrogativi fondamentali sul piano
etico e sul piano filosofico ma lasciamo
da parte un attimo l'informatica la vera
novità è questo
più importante contributo di kraft swan
e che sono esponenziali tutte le
tecnologie che sono basate sulle
informazioni
questo cambia completamente tutto questo
significa che intelligenza artificiale e
robotica biologia sintetica nono
tecnologie tutte queste tecnologie ce ne
sono delle altre sono esponenziali e
questo tratto si accelerano a vicenda
perché si fertilizzano a vicenda e
questo significa che quello che abbiamo
visto con questa roba qui è il preludio
di un cambiamento molto più epocale che
ci coglierà completamente di sorpresa
questo è un esempio di esponenziale
potentissimo vi ricorderete che nel 2003
c'è scritto 2013 ma dev'essere 2003 è
stato annunciato il successo del
progetto di decodifica del genoma umano
ci sono voluti 13 anni un investimento
di 3 miliardi di dollari oggi per
decodificare un genoma umano ci si mette
una settimana costa 1.000 dollari e fra
enel nel 2020 probabilmente ci vorrà
dieci minuti e costerà un centesimo
praticamente la biologia si è fusa con
la chimica che si è fusa con la
ingegneria soprattutto si è fusa con
l'informatica ora guardiamo le cellule
come dei processori e al dna come di un
linguaggio di programmazione sul quale
potremo intervenire nel bene e nel male
io sostengo soprattutto nel del bene
certo è che qui sta nascendo una
industria gigantesca un po come è
successo con con i computer quando è
arrivato il personal computer
parlando di fertilizzazione questo è un
altro esempio di fertilizzazione
informatica la macchina auto guidata che
praticamente il matrimonio fra la
macchina tra una macchina e un computer
questa macchina compiuto milioni di
chilometri senza alcun danno diciamo
senza incidenti di rilievo se il
buongiorno si vede dal mattino questo
significa che qui c'è il potenziale per
salvare un milione di vite umane
che già di per sé sarebbe un cambiamento
profondissimo pro i cambiamenti che
diciamo arriverebbero se si affermasse
la macchina auto guidata sono vanno
anche molto più in là per esempio
pensate a come cambierebbe
l'architettura della nostra città che
oggi sono piene zeppe di parcheggi
pensate alla mobilita di persone anziane
e disabili
il business delle assicurazioni sarà
completamente sconvolto e poi quale sarà
l'impatto sul pil nell aver eliminato
miliardi di ore trascorse in questo modo
per non parlare del fatto che queste
macchine sono dei degenti degli dei
super generatori di dati dati che
potremo utilizzare per creare nuovi
servizi
parlando di dati dalla crescita delle
informazioni digitali e esponenziali
anche anch'essa questa è una fan famoso
calcolo fatto da eric schmidt di google
che ha calcolato che dall'inizio dei
tempi fino al 2003 abbiamo prodotto 55
miliardi di gigabyte di informazioni di
dati la stessa quantità l'abbiamo
prodotta in due giorni nel 2010 e la
stessa quantità l'abbiamo prodotta in
dieci minuti nel 2013 abbiamo cominciato
col testo poi le foto poi video poi
social
adesso arrivano gli oggetti si calcola
che entro dieci anni e gli oggetti
connessi ad internet saranno mille
miliardi
questa frase la tecnologia sostituirà la
80 per cento dei dottori entro dieci
anni
questo lo sostiene i fondatori di sun
microsystems
potrà sembrare fantascienza e forse lo è
non lo sappiamo
certo è che anche la penicillina
sarebbe sembrata fantascienza nel 1900
la tac fantascienza nel 1950 e la stessa
decodifica del genoma umano nel 1990 le
tecnologie esponenziali stanno sfumando
i confini fra fantascienza in realtà è
questa per esempio è in realtà è ed è
anche fantascienza messo insieme
questo è un premio messo in palio dalla
fondazione ex price da qualcomm di 10
milioni di dollari che praticamente ha
lanciato una sfida ma non hanno lanciato
una sfida a start upper e ricercatori
per creare un palmare per intenderci
come quello di star tech in grado di
battere 10 dottori nel diagnosticare le
più frequenti malattie
il vincitore sarà annunciato a breve
altro che fantascienza altro esempio
nanotecnologie applicate alla fia
l'efficienza dei pannelli solari
anche qui assistiamo dei raddoppi di
efficienza da diverso tempo a questa
parte
se questo trend continua anna
fantascienza o ancora una volta fra 20
anni avremo risolto il problema
dell'energia è ancora più importante
avremo risolto il problema dell'acqua
che strettamente connesso a quello
dell'energia grandi trasformazioni in
atto allora siamo preparati a giudicare
dall esempio che avevo fatto prima
direi di no siamo preparati c'è proprio
un gap cognitivo le tecnologie
esponenziali vanno così e il nostro modo
di pensare va così lo vediamo anche dal
fatto che abbiamo che lavoriamo cioè che
abbiamo creato funzioniamo utilizzando
delle strutture che si basano su modelli
organizzativi creati 100 200 anni fa i
governi le scuole nel sistema dei
brevetti il sistema legale tutte tutti i
modelli organizzativi pensati per un
mondo che era lineare sostanzialmente
statico e quindi anche abbastanza
prevedibile mentre questo mondo presto
non esisterà più e la cosa importante è
che questo cambiamento è in atto è reale
ed è inarrestabile e allora porterà con
sé una serie di come sempre col
progresso una serie di minacce e di
opportunità di pericoli e di opportunità
ecco parlando di pericoli io come padre
di questi bambini
il pericolo lo prendo molto sul serio no
ho sentito parlare di privacy cyber
terrorismo algoritmi software che
distruggono posti di lavoro
all'inazione della realtà virtuale che
più ne ha più ne metta ma dubito che
mettersi il casco risolva il problema
piuttosto dobbiamo intervenire su quello
che sta sotto il casco io personalmente
penso che sia molto importante cambiare
la nostra mentalità cambiare avere una
mentalità orientata al cambiamento che
una mentalità una orientata alla
innovazione e una imprenditorialità
orientata è improntata alla
sostenibilità e all'uso delle tecnologie
a fin di bene e questo è un po il
diciamo l'idea una delle idee
fondamentali della singularity
university tempi sulla quale torno
adesso da simulare che nella city
seleziona tutti gli anni i più brillanti
talenti del mondo mi fa venire in
california e dice loro ragazzi non siete
questo tanto per studiare scegliete uno
di questi problemi è dato un contributo
pensate a come si possono usare le
tecnologie esponenziali per impattare
positivamente su un miliardo di persone
entro dieci anni
una sfida unica è entusiasmante e poi i
migliori progetti vengono selezionati o
come diventano di progetti di ricerca
oppure oppure vengono diciamo incubati e
diventano dei business incubati
direttamente al singolare che university
adesso vi faccio vedere un esempio di
questi progetti realizzati da un
italiano un giovane talento di 22 anni
alberto rizzoli che ha scelto il
problema della salute in particolare
quello della cecità e la tecnologia
scelta quella dell'intelligenza
artificiale ha sviluppato
un'applicazione che serve ai ciechi per
riconoscere gli oggetti che si trovano
di fronte a loro vediamo ai poi i
sentimenti del prode based
basta
all
per noi
ecco avete visto dice light magic
no mi ha fatto pensare a quella fase di
esser clark l'autore di odissea nello
spazio che diceva ogni tecnologia
sufficientemente avanzata
indistinguibile dalla magia ecco se
abbracciamo il cambiamento è invece di
resistere e lo cavalchiamo e se diciamo
immaginate un milione di imprenditori
tutti orientati a voler fare del bene
oltre che del business
ecco i risultati sarebbero
indistinguibili dalla magia grazie